Básicamente, si haces un diseño en la computadora
y se lo mandas a la máquina esta cortará las siluetas que quieras
de manera rápida y precisa.
Pero en esta máquina en particular
puedes cambiar el cortador de plasma por un huso
para que puedas tallar madera.
Esto fue diseñado por mi Jefe de Ingeniería,
su nombre es Wachira y cuando lo contraté hace unos dos años
le dije: "Solo dame dos años y cuando hayas entrenado a mucha gente,
y haya muchas personas bajo tu mando,
entonces te vas y te conviertes en una buena historia para contar".
Y eso pasó.
Tiene dos tipos de compradores.
El comprador de más alto nivel es una compañía que usa su máquina
para cortar láminas de metal para fabricar camiones Isuzu en Nairobi,
bajo la dirección de General Motors.
Así que estamos muy orgullosos de poder decir
que tenemos un fabricante de equipos originales en Nairobi
que ha proveído lo que es, en efecto, un robot industrial
que suple de piezas a General Motors.
Esto es muy importante…
(Aplausos)
es importante porque siendo el crecimiento poblacional lo que es
muchas grandes compañías están viendo de cerca
el mercado que crece en África.
Así que en Kenia ahora tenemos a Volkswagen, Peugeot, Renault,
a Mercedes haciendo camiones, a Toyota que está allí desde hace tiempo.
Todos esos fabricantes planean ensamblar vehículos
y, en el futuro, fabricar en el país.
Varios planean entrenar a mucha gente cuando la contraten,
que es importante para la economía.
Pero lo realmente mágico ocurrirá cuando estas compañías
empiecen a comprar las partes que necesitan para los vehículos
a las compañías locales.
Así que desarrollar la cadena de suministros es realmente importante
para que podamos tener economías muy productivas.
Y estamos enfocados en eso en nuestro espacio.
Esta imagen muestra el otro tipo de cliente quel tiene.
Arriba a la izquierda
están personas que usan herramientas rudimentarias
para trabajar metal y madera.
Kenia tiene una población de cerca de 44 millones de personas.
La fuerza laboral es de 13 millones
y entre el 80 y 90 % de ellos está en el sector informal.
Lo que ven en esa imagen es típico de los artesanos semicalificados
que hacen productos para el mercado
que son toscos.
La tasa de producción es muy lenta, la calidad del producto no es alta.
Así que asociamos a Wachira con un banco.
Y el banco le está pagando para que entrene a gente de este sector
en el uso de este robot industrial.
El resultado es que algunos de ellos
van a obtener préstamos para comprarse estas máquinas.
Otros irán a centros donde podrán llevar sus materiales, imprimir su diseño
y, rápidamente, regresar con los materiales que ya están listos
para ensamblarlos en sus propios locales.
Por ejemplo, alguien que hace un portón de metal
puede demorarse una semana en hacer una puerta,
pero con la máquina haría 10 puertas en un día.
Así que la productividad de una gran parte de la población
podría hacer un salto cuántico en lo que respecta a cantidad
gracias a esta máquina.
Y estamos recién comenzando, así que es muy emocionante.
Esta es otra persona que usa nuestro espacio.
Se llama Esther, tiene veintitantos años
y tiene una gran pasión por un problema que nos explicó.
Dijo que la chicas faltan muchos días a la escuela debido a su ciclo menstrual
porque no pueden comprar toallas sanitarias.
La razón que nos dio
fue que los fabricantes empacan las toallas en grupos de 7 a 10.
Separarlas en las tiendas sería poco higiénico
y empaquetarlas individualmente es demasiado caro.
Así que pensó en una solución que es brillante y simple.
¿Por qué no usamos máquinas expendedoras?
Ella, en un ambiente muy limpio,
puede dividir los paquetes y llenar las máquinas expendedoras
para que las chicas puedan comprar las toallas sanitarias
en la privacidad de un baño, espacio público, escuela, etc.
Hizo un prototipo para esto que funcionó extremadamente bien
y ha sido capaz de ir solucionando las fallas.
Así que lo importante aquí es que es posible hacer prototipos.
No es ingeniera, empleó a la gente de nuestro espacio para que la ayude
y ahora está trabajando con una aceleradora de empresas,
así que esperamos grandes resultados.
(Aplausos)
Esta imagen que ven
es el resultado de un proyecto de posgrado hecho en la Universidad de Nairobi
por Tony Nyagah, un estudiante de ingeniería.
Integró una célula solar en una teja de techo
y decidió convertirlo en un negocio.
Se asoció con su hermana, que es arquitecta, y tienen este negocio.
Presentan la teja a una persona que está construyendo y le dicen:
"Puedes comprarla por el costo de la teja sin el panel solar",
así que la dan en descuento
y las fabrican usando el Internet de las cosas.
Con el tiempo, con la instalación se paga un tercio de la tarifa de electricidad
y se puede vender el exceso de energía a la red eléctrica nacional.
Así que ganarán su dinero con el tiempo.
Ya han hecho varias instalaciones.
Estuvimos muy orgullosos de poder enseñarle esto a alguien medio famoso,
ahí lo pueden ver, y este otro tipo famoso
presentó la misma idea,
pero consideramos que lo hizo después que nosotros, así que…
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Para cerrar:
hacer prototipos y fabricar a bajo costo en este tipo de ambiente
es muy importante para el proceso de industrialización.
Pero también aprovechamos muchas de las nuevas maneras de hacer las cosas:
el movimiento Open Source, la fabricación local y economía circular.
Todo eso es importante no solo para industrializarse
y para satisfacer las necesidades de la gente,
sino también para proteger al medio ambiente.
También nos interesa la cultura.
Tenemos muchas discusiones en nuestro espacio
sobre quiénes éramos como africanos, quiénes somos y quiénes queremos ser.
Hablamos de consumismo, etnicidad, corrupción, etc.
Pensamos que nosotros le añadimos valor a la gente
al enseñarles a añadir valor a las cosas o materiales
para que puedan construir cosas que importan.
Muchísimas gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.